the ultimate undisputed queen of tick
tock is charlie demilia
you know she's the app's number one
creator with over 100 million followers
and counting and only our
kelty knight had a chance to sit down
with charlie to talk about her money
moves
i am not exactly the person that
i portray myself on my tick tock videos
at the end of the day i am a girl that
likes to dance and likes to spend time
with her friends and
likes to be around her family stop
playing with a red light green light
she's 16 a competitive dancer the second
highest paid tick tock star making up to
100
000 per post has an estimated net worth
of eight million
and she hasn't even graduated high
school oh and after the super bowl
these two are among charlie's celebrity
fans
[Applause]
[Music]
i saw j.lo and a-rod not that long ago
and
they were just like yeah you just can't
be caught up in what's going on that's
wrong
it's just like you really need to push
forward and i was like you said
everything that i needed to hear
that is insane walk it out
walk it out to celebrate 100 million you
donated a hundred thousand dollars to
dance charities and studios why was that
so important to you
for me i grew up with a lot of
anxiety and if i was never put into
dance i would not have any confidence
and post videos for millions of people
to see it i would have never been able
to do that
[Music]
charlie also knows the downside of fame
her on-again
off-again relationship with fellow tick
tock star little huddy
constantly makes headlines think of
those two as the brad and jen
for the top generation how much pressure
does it put on you when everyone's so
involved
in your relationships you're like wow
these people are
more invested in seeing us fail
then they want to see us actually be
happy together even having to announce
that
you're broken up with someone makes it a
million times worse
charlie's also faced her share of haters
who post comments like she quote
looked better a year ago that's part of
what led the teen to telling her story
her way
in a new book essentially charlie it's a
book
you read it and that's it
there's no place for negative feedback
this is a place for me to share who i
am without having to hear anything back